we are transitioning remember from
thinking about psychos and Tanner's
trigonometric ratios right within a
triangle there's this quantity this
length and this length about comparing
them right we're moving away from that
by thinking well what are they as
functions just as rules and what we did
was we introduced a means by which about
the triangle a different geometric
figure we used to define the trig
functions what were they what was it so
the unit circle wasn't it okay which is
why I'm just going to quickly draw it
for myself you don't need to because
you'll have your one from last lesson to
refer to and you'll need to the unit
circle we said that we defined the
coordinates based on the trig functions
okay we said anywhere on the
circumference wherever you're on the
circumference the coordinates of that
point will be cos theta sine theta where
theater is the angle subtended visit
nice familiarity September that the
origin between your point the origin and
which side of the x-axis the positive
side the xn plus what are we here okay
so for instance in this diagram my feet
up would be there okay so we took this
idea and we know this was very very
powerful okay because number one it took
us outside of what we would call the
first quadrant right which is the cutie
at angles we can look at angles of any
magnitude right and not just that you
looked at boundary values for these
values which wouldn't make sense in a
triangle like this if Peter were say 90
degrees okay from the unit circle
definition
what's for instance cos of 90 have a
look at it
cosine is the x-coordinate which for
that point is 0 right 0 and of course
it's a tendon y value would be 1 which
is why we say sine of 90 degrees is 1 it
comes from this this is the definition
ok so now we're gonna do is we're gonna
transition everybody more if it's a
function you can graph a function you
can grab any function you like ok based
on what values that you get right so
here's the way we're going to approach
this instead of having X's and Y's ok
just to remind you that what we really
would be are angles I'm gonna call this
the theta axis right and then well for
this graph because the first one I'm
always gonna start with just sign this
is the sine theta axis now I know you're
used to saying well x and y x y but Y is
just another name for whatever function
you got in there like say y equals x
squared you just as equally could have
named the axes X and x squared because Y
is equal to x squared and that would
give you this okay so we're gonna graph
feed our against sine theta right so
where we gonna begin is we're just gonna
think about the peak bits that are easy
right some bits are very easy if I look
for example at an angle of 0 okay down
there okay the key is sine so which of
the chord it's making on X or Y I am
picking alphabetically rights and sine
is up y-coordinate right so what's the
y-coordinate of this angle the answer is
0 so sine theta for theta equals 0 is 0
okay and then I can keep going through
the angles I'm gonna start by using the
important points there those boundary
points because they'll give me sort of
the spires I need to go right so we were
talking about 90 degrees okay so I'm
gonna put some markers on here I'm gonna
put 4 you can probably see why it's
going before okay so make that first one
90 degrees right sine of 90 is 1 it's
one now before I'm marking cuz I don't
have a vertical scale on here right
donate to this yet just think about it
your head where should I put it
what should I put it like okay I'm going
to put it right up there in fact I'm
gonna make it the highest value I can
get soon and the reason why comes back
to the fact we're on the unit circle
right if sign and it causes the same but
if sine is the Y value right the very
highest I get is one because that's the
highest it goes on the unit circle and
conversely the very lowest I can go is
negative one okay
so right away I've got a range for my
[ __ ] so far side equals 90 degrees
I'm up and what I'm gonna keep going
around the circle for theta equals 180
degrees I've got a straight angle there
and so what's the y coordinate what is
the sign dying I'm back to zero Anna
okay
that's for a hundred and eighty degrees
and then I can keep going you'll see
what's happening I'll come around to
this side down here for 270 degrees so
sine theta4 that is negative one okay so
that's for 207 and then my last value D
is 360 okay now 360 takes me back to
where I started because it's a circle
right so that's y 0 for 360 degrees now
I could keep going but I don't need you
I don't need to do one because look what
happens right as I keep going to say for
instance I said 450 degrees okay it's
the angle subtended at the center right
so where's 450 I have to go all the way
around that's 360 and then I have to go
another 90 right that would that would
get me to 450 yes okay but that's
exactly the same thing that happened
when I went up tonight so this pattern
is going to repeat right because I'm
literally going around in circles okay
so that's what I'm going to stop drawing
before I connect the dots right I could
connect the dots in a variety of ways
and in fact one of reasons why I'm
making a big deal out this even though
many of you have seen this before
because I want to highlight some of bad
ways to do this okay
for instance if I told you he's 1 2 3
points okay 1 2 3 points I could draw
for you I'm just going to draw it on the
side I could draw for you a graph that
passes through those 1 2 3 points that
is exactly a graph that you have been
working on over the last few weeks right
for instance let's just draw that part
there 1 2 3
if those are the points that gave you
how could I join these up any
suggestions
yeah me too yeah excellent I could just
check a straight line all right I'll get
to that in a second okay so for starters
that that satisfies the points doesn't
it right because I don't have many
points I don't have enough detail of
what's going on and what would the
present of that be
I have no idea it would be minus
absolute value of x plus plus something
90 degrees whatever okay you get the
idea so that's um that's not gonna work
though because quite clearly different
functions that's a good another
suggestion that would still pass through
all three points is I could try to be
them with a semicircle right just the
last quiz we did there was the equation
of a semicircle image you could contrive
that equation both of those aren't good
fits right so I need a little more data
in here to fill this in and get an
accurate shape I'm gonna stop talking
for a second in between 0 and 180 even
between 0 and 90 ok we know a series of
the exact values that will give us cert
then I'd like you to go ahead and put in
here do it as accurately as you can
I'll give you a couple of minutes you
have zero but that 30 45 60 and then 90
which we already have so I'm looking for
three values and they're gonna give us a
shape in
off you go so I'm gonna quickly do some
of this by hand while I don't have a
choice okay 30 45 and 60 30 45 and 60
now because I'm very excited right I
know right away that sine 30 degrees is
1/2 right so think about it this way
I've only gone a third the way
horizontally eyford the way horizontally
but I'm already halfway up my vertical
scale because I'm at a half right so
I've climbed my grady in there is quite
steep right when you get to sine 45 sine
45 degrees is 102 which of the decimal
is zero point seven oh seven I think so
by a half way I'm already like 3/4 the
way up so this is the kind of shape you
want okay that's the kind of shape you
should be have it now you can go ahead
and you can test that what's happening
here on the circle because of this
symmetry here right as I go from zero
and 19 the Y value is increasing when I
go from 90 to 180 the Y value is
decreasing at exactly the same rate in
Reverse does that make sense like I'm
literally climbing down the other side
of the circle okay so I'm gonna get the
same shape I'm gonna get it down okay
and now I'm going to continue my pattern
to meet up with all the other points
I've got okay now have talked before
about templates okay that's a really
easy way to just nail it straight away
but in the absence of a template there
are three important things and I'm
looking for three appointed things
number one this gradient here and see
that gradient right this should be a
gradient it mustn't be a vertical
tangent like like it would be if it was
a semi circle or an ellipse okay so I'm
looking for a gradient there in fact if
you do everything to scale and we'll get
to Radian strongly that grainy there is
in fact one now it doesn't look like one
on my diagram and almost certainly on
yours because our scale
are different and that that's fine as
long as you're consistent that's fine
okay but my point is there must be a
gradient it can't be vertical that was
number one number two I'm looking for a
smooth transition here as the grainy
goes from steep and then sort of levels
out that should happen smoothly we joked
about this absolute value thing before
I've seen loads of graphs that sort of
look like an absolute value all the way
and then they come like oh oh I'd better
turn around I'll just tuck a little
thing there and then just keep going
okay so it's like an absolute value in
everything but these little corners okay
it's still not okay this should be a
smooth transition now as a second thing
I'm looking for the last thing is up
here at night earrings and down here at
270 degrees okay these things are what
we call they have a couple of names but
the most relevant name to this is it's a
turning point toward a turning point
because the function literally turns
around hot it's not going up anymore
it's not increasing it's decreasing that
turning point should be nice and gentle
in fact when I'm drawing grass freehand
often the turning points will be the
first thing I draw right to make sure I
get them right and then I connect
everything else okay so what are the
three things number one what's happening
is I possibly the axis here and here and
here and I can keep going number two
am i smoothly transitioning the gradient
and number three what's happening at the
turning points am I getting that shape
right now we have finished what's
happening over here okay but there's a
whole half of my graph that is busy
right I've got all of these negative
angles over negative angles don't make
sense when you're triangle but in the
unit circle there's no reason why you
can't do a negative angle what direction
do positive angles going on what
direction okay
antique clockwise right don't do that
right
yeah okay 80 yeah right yeah let's not
do it cuz I'm confused myself Eddie got
wise right so therefore negative that
girls should go clockwise right they
still start at the same point we still
start at that positive x-axis but for
instance minus 45 degrees we go down to
here okay so you can see I'm going to
get the same graph but it's going to be
reflected across so let's just finish
drawing I should have said maybe a
fourth thing which I'm pointing up
because I haven't done it very well on
this my turning points should all be at
1 and minus 1 they should all be there
it's very hard to do it by hand just why
I tell you guys to get a template it's
just so easy they think